[Música]
[Aplausos]
fez e que possa compartilhar um
pouquinho do aprendizado que eu tive ao
viver e poder escrever esse livro que eu
chamo de filho círculo vicioso
espero que seja bastante pra vocês
você começa falando um pouco sobre o que
é o muricy ozu seria de pensar na
situação que a gente vive hoje a gente
está abrindo 15 círculos viciosos master
iniciante a começou a ser pessoas
representando países com situações que
incomoda muita gente às vezes propulsor
ativo que é onde a gente vive e é muito
importante a gente trabalha com esse
mundo a gente tem que ser feliz sabendo
isso a gente também de círculos viciosos
terríveis de pessoas que são pessoas e
talvez não termine aqui
todas as pessoas consigam encontrar o
caminho para ter a felicidade fazenda
sefaz gostado que é do estado e em todos
os dias
então a gente vive números círculos
viciosos a pergunta que eu gosto de
fazer com as pessoas com as quais me
relaciono sejam elas pessoas que
trabalham comigo ou com o meu trabalho
mas o que é que você já pensou sobre
qual é o seu círculo vicioso porque
talvez você não gosta da empresa que
você trabalha porque você fala tomar o
seu chefe ou porque a empresa está ruim
ou será que você que talvez não esteja
fazendo as refeições corretas porque
será que é tão difícil se engajar coisas
que todos os dias a gente vive que devia
ser tão fácil
essas coisas são difíceis diante a gente
precisa pensar profundamente para
encontrar respostas e novos vídeos
depois que a gente quebra esse primeiro
círculo vicioso que começa a montar o
que nós somos a gente encontra
os novos esses caminhos novos são
caminhos que a data é impossível em casa
a gente sem pessoal mas a gente sempre
imaginou difícil é igual distante nós
estamos delas
então a gente sonha com coisas que não
são atingíveis que são fáceis alguns
nomes e parece que a gente se conforma
tanto isso a gente aceita nenhuma vida
talvez não possa quando sentir atraente
eu gosto de trocar em favor das pessoas
é uma provocação
todas as pessoas que trabalham comigo
nas mais de 100 empresas com as quais
relacionou hoje a gente sempre mais esse
palco cantando qual é o seu propósito
porque você faz o que você faz e aceita
porque você é assim que eu gosto de usar
isso para mostrar que mesmo no ar há uma
relação de emprego empregador o
empregado é a tua alma tão deteriorado a
gente testa tanto tudo isso tem caminhos
em seu caminho fácil de se encontrar
esses caminhos são aumentados em
propósitos sobretudo propósitos de vida
um sentido para nós
de acordo com o que são valores que pra
que a gente possa com conduzir a nossa
trajetória e não era natural
eu gosto muito dessa frase quem não
porque enfrenta o everton é fácil a
gente já de si mesmo
infelizmente existem muitas
empresas são as pessoas mas como nunca
tinha visto empresas começam a perguntar
às pessoas com os pais ela seja ela se
relaciona sejam colaboradores ou rins
quais são os novos talentos possam as
novas possibilidades de o que te faz
feliz e isso tem sido a tônica de uma
caminhada nova pelo que eu chamo de uma
convergência de propósitos que o inter
este ano o mesmo interesse que o papa
tem que ensinar a filha andar de
bicicleta pode brincar com o filho fosse
encontrar uma família e afetivamente
é isso que vai fazer com que a gente de
novo as barreiras ao mítico as
indesejáveis que muitas vezes nós
colocamos no ambiente de trabalho e
talvez aceitamos muitas barreiras que
são colocados à nossa outras palavras
essa convergência de propósitos um
interesse genuíno máximo mundial algo
que talvez seja ficando muito rápido no
mundo digital
a gente manda no texto fala
se conectar com as pessoas essa conversa
de morte
essa conversa tem sido freqüente dizem
os especialistas que são dezenas de
vezes mas aquela pessoa que se interessa
senão a gente perde o outro mas eu não
vou desistir dos meus filhos nunca vou
assistir as pessoas que eu amo
não vamos desistir da minha esposa
também família nunca porque tenho amor
eu não preciso dizer que eu amo as
pessoas que trabalham comigo também não
vai se chamar um cheque
a gente só precisa de mão de justiça e
as possibilidades de participação sejam
imparciais campais
isso é super como nunca é desejado em
todos os lugares por onde passo as
pessoas dizem nossa como eu adoraria na
malha da empresa mas eu não sei se eu
sou empreendedor para criaria então
mundialmente você vê a mais o último que
tentou mudar o ambiente onde vivia foi
mandado embora vai embora um gosto
porque a empresa alemã provavelmente
bola não merece nenhum
agora não vejo a vida passar como se
você simplesmente tivesse gastando
a importância do protagonismo que a
gente exige dos outros
nós temos que viver começa com uma moça
sons
eu digo isso na filosofia de gestão do
meu primeiro livro de janeiro fala um
pouco mais profunda atingir segunda lá
um círculo vicioso
são quatro pilares básicos tudo que você
for fazer na sua vida na sua empresa
em momentos de lazer você precisa estar
e substancial de para fazer sentido na
sua então quando você vai montar um
sentimento na sua empresa e infelizmente
os procedimentos existem até porque tem
pessoas que queria que são criativas e
criam coisas que talvez não faça algum
sentido para todo porque elas estão mais
no indivíduo e usam até advogado geral
então a gente precisa fazer coisas que
não sejam é somente nas gírias algumas
vezes precisam pensar com quem vai viver
alguém depois dentro vai fazer aquilo
que você acredita em tanto mas tanto de
produção
todas as estruturas de comando e
controle que são importadas dos países
que criam essas ferramentas incríveis
chegam aqui funciona basicamente nós
precisamos acreditar por opção que vai
sentir se eu acredito em uma coisa com
certeza mais gente pode acreditar mas se
eu construí uma coisa na bola eu
acredito que faça total sentido para o
outro
osvaldo então você não vai precisar de
estruturas severas de comando e controle
geralmente nos locais que chateiam todo
mundo pra fazer com que as coisas sejam
feitas as coisas serão feitas
simplesmente porque fazem de as coisas
são feitas porque as pessoas optam por
fazer
ninguém pode obrigar a opção de uma
pessoa
nas brs em direito constitucional é
verdade
agora quando eu acredito em parte por
opção
tudo melhor inclusive a vida das pessoas
porque se nós fizermos isso sociedade
dentro da coletividade
a gente não é nem mesmo a nossa gente
porque nós estamos unidos e acreditamos
que enquanto todas essas coisas mesmo
quando não tiver na moda mesmo quando
pega mal paga imposto passem para com os
povos é comum não é só você é ótimo tem
problema nenhum se eu precisasse a
ultimarem os principais eu vou fazer
shows até agora tudo tem que melhorar
mas melhor por convicção e eu acredito
que por opção e melhor o missal fácil
consolidar esse comportamento
com as pessoas porque certamente sem ter
não temos pessoas são céticas jogam mais
sagradas já sofreram que sofreram muito
nós não acredita em muita coisa
infelizmente muitas e muitas vezes nós
não nem elas mesmas
então o trabalho de cultura de resgate e
fortalecimento de coisas que nós não
aprendemos quando éramos crianças
tínhamos valores muito bem colocados
quando a gente chega no controle
operativo fato sabe soila santo hoje
então se a gente puder compartilhar a
gente consolida isso e faz com que a
sociedade evoluiu bastante
não vou passar cada uma das dimensões
não várias o site de tecnologia de
gestão ao velho se espalhando a todas as
escolas podem lavar os pés a vida o
mundo do trabalho a competitividade
tudo aquilo que rege a nossa linda no
dia a dia
segundo ativo é um vídeo infelizmente
por décadas nós importamos modelos onde
não se pensar o único lar que ela
trabalhava era o lado da efetividade
manda quem pode obedece quem tem juízo
porrada resultado não deve estar na vila
bom
para convencer um rebolado e por muito
mas muito tempo esse foi o único modelo
de gestão os movimentos nesse mundo
tradicional foi a foi parte do mundo que
os nossos pais e com certeza nossa voz
do governo e aceitar muito por falta de
opção
talvez porque não conseguiam ser
inovadores ao ombro de amor mas quando a
gente pensa no mundo mais ano nós
equilibramos as coisas em tão importante
quanto seletivo fazer o resultado
acontecer é o lado afetivo
não faço sozinho funcionava assim alguém
e é com isso que vamos mundo que faz
mais sentido quando os resultados
acontecem de forma orgânica e natural
porque as pessoas querem sobretudo
porque os aspectos da atividade desse
encontro
se fosse simples não existe cidade
existe um ambiente equilibrado entre a
efetividade do nosso precisamos ter com
a atividade nós precisamos ser sobretudo
os 312 do outro no ambiente de trabalho
e as melhores práticas a imensa saudade
é tão feliz com o momento em que alguém
faz uma coisa maravilhosa para o cliente
sem você pedir
você não precisa fazer o carro
obrigar-se ali você não precisa de uma
dezenas centenas ou milhares chefe
o pessoal por fazer porque aqui eu
simplesmente faz sentido a ela
nós teremos nesse mundo onde tudo é
importante ter e evoluímos não é
problema nenhum poder ter coisas é uma
base necessária mas eu converso com toda
a efetividade da costa só da minha vida
querendo ter coisas mas quando eu erro
eu deixo de eu apenas querer coisas
passo a ser hoje por todos e essa
atividade combinada com a efetividade de
trabalho sério digno indisciplinado faz
com que eu acredito sempre me deu uma
oportunidade nova e mais alguém
quando eu faço isso eu estou ficando
melhor consigo compartilhar de novo
contagiando pessoas que já estão
desanimadas
quantas vezes eu fizesse ciclo virtuoso
que chama de ciclo porque ele não
termina dele mesmo com um silo ele
continuam uma espiral definir qual a
minha consciência se ter um cargo
importante é valoroso pra você pode ter
certeza absoluta que vivia num mundo
onde você entrou outro
isso vai acontecer mais fácil mais
rápido e vai ser só
empresas todas as linhas a gente fala
sobre como ter estes talentos incríveis
querendo trabalhar gaúcho
há retenção a redenção existe mais como
receber uma pessoa sala tem direito à
liberdade
a gente precisa é encampar essa pessoa e
esse encantamento é possível se pode ir
desde que nós sejamos pessoas
a gente sai desse modelo tradicional
onde propor principalmente uma pensa vai
pro modelo voz o pedaço da pizza forma
alguma coisa nova
eu continuo pensando com estratégia e
inovação dinamismo residência disciplina
ao resultado cinco porque é fundamental
isso no mundo dos negócios
ninguém quer perder dinheiro mas nós
fazemos isso com uma nova forma uma
forma que faz total sentido das pessoas
e que não tinham autonomia eo
protagonismo a qualidade vida à vontade
porque a única forma de fazer com que
ela só queria deixar a empresa informa
que ela não esteja na hora de ir embora
para ser eficaz ela precisa ser
realizada todo dia
o dinheiro a mais a felicidade é
contínuo no paraná
olha eu gosto de buscar coisas que são
legais podendo todo
o ano de momentos possível ea empresa
que é esperta pensando em fazer isso
porque as instituições que vão prosperar
são elas não precisam lavar em dois
tipos de liderança que trabalha nisso
se você se vê nessa liderança cinza
provavelmente você dá emprego por um bom
tempo mas se você já está à venda na
sardinha aonde você agrega em televisão
falar nos outros envolve espíritos a fia
ou seja como bem mas vocês vão perceber
no brasil gravar
existem duas anomalias a primeira ainda
outro lado ele ainda assim o caminho que
a gente tem esse tipo de estrutura
quando você chega no lugar não consegue
saber que o gerente
nós queremos ou jeff
toda sua carreira vai prosperar do mundo
a gente pensar empresas assim que ainda
pensa divisão que são valores relatados
e compradas de uma prateleira
a gente precisa pensar na razão de ser
desse negócio e o quanto ele pode atrair
gente do bem que quer fazer a diferença
que vai praticar corrupção vai melhorar
a conexão que compartilha com todos o
que é isso que faz sentido para a gente
mudar sim em aberto a qualquer pessoa
que queira e rolar a gente dizia chega
precisa de pessoas que optam por fazê lo
fazem cinema na o executivo que se veste
de palhaço para o hospital do câncer de
igual a criança a sobre de novo
é difícil talvez alguns de nossos
empregados circuito não tenho nem
condição emocional para fazer todas as
contas são de vocês mas aquelas que você
enfrente luta e não existe
chegou a um ponto apenas colherá os
culpados como também poderá compartilhar
pessoas
os caminhos que você fez eu estou aqui
[Música]
e você já tem o seu tempo de você
a empresa precisa de nós para que nós
possamos equilibrar o juntos a gente
pode transformar ó resolver o problema
do time não apenas milhares e milhares
de vidas
a gente possa transformar o sistema todo
que a gente precisa é conversar
obrigado